Hales compress my name is beard welcome
back to Abzu part three this is a very
cool game I recommend you check out part
one what are you doing on part three if
you have watched part two and whatever
the [ __ ] you plays this little diver
dude
hey you backflip that's like the best
thing about the game the back flips
we're about to go here I completely
forgot the controls here we go
now if when I played the game it had
hasn't been released yet so the big
feature about this game I believe is
that you can play it with a random
stranger so I think soon I don't know
what could happen at any point someone
else is gonna join us randomly someone
will get to play with a great putti pine
and they won't even know about it
I'm only saying that because that's how
people commented about when I was
playing journey people like oh my god
they could be playing with pittypat and
they wouldn't even know about it how
horrific no there are definitely worse
things oh [ __ ] if you tap a he he swims
like a bus I always pick the worst
places to end the videos I am so sorry
about that by the way like this is
clearly where I should and not ended it
yet
alright so we say hi little the space
blob I think we have one or two more of
these and they're fairly short and
journey was about two hour long but it's
weird I can't really feel the pace of
this game the same way I've already
played this I'm [ __ ] idiot
let's try and get a little bit more
serious all right I know I just started
but I knew I want to immerse myself okay
that's that's what's beautiful about
this game after all
what are you doing Wales you can't swim
with that water
can someone just tell them please it was
really great to see that so many of you
bros were as intrigued and interested in
this game as I was it really is
impressive if you look at all the fishes
and be likable it still runs so smoothly
it feels like an alive world
look at it look at all its beauty and
all its colors let's keep going and
maybe I can not control the camera
angles properly I'm so sorry okay
uh it seems like it I'm just really
worried because I want someone else to
join me it's such a cute thing when you
whoa okay we find something
also keep commenting your theories about
the story I think it's really
interesting
it made the fishes go outside the water
okay so it is actually a thing
cool
I think we're swimming up now let's
check it so they gather the water from
the bottom of that Sun the Sun in the
bottom of the ocean and then they took
that and they poured it in the ocean
which made the fishes swim out and then
that built the great I'm so sorry the
great coral thing this is fantastic
I love this I love this okay now we need
to keep going
oh yeah here's the water so there's
water in the water I'm not crazy
there is water in the water everyone I
mean technically it is possible all
right more story I believe it's a bit
hard to see here so we came that's us
and what do we do the divers
I don't know
[ __ ] [ __ ] up probably
are we the ones building these no that's
just crazy
okay am I supposed to do something here
I am I should have done that first what
about a lot easier to see
I don't understand I'm not even going to
pretend that I do but like I said if you
have theories leave them in the comments
yeah let's keep going baby
hmm
whoo LaLanne sopretty
the the absurd drinking game with Peter
Pye drink every time I compliment how
pretty the game is it matters to me okay
shut up
okay sharks and [ __ ] got it more sharks
and [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is that green eel
that's terrifying
oh I touch my face disgusting have you
seen eels slab calm that was literally
the same thing that happened okay we are
being fed a little bit of serene context
here but I'm not sure if I quite still
get it I remember journey was even
harder to understand or maybe I'm just
an idiot that's it thank you very much
though okay this is creepy
great let's look like very spiky rocks
that could kill me I'm gonna try my best
not to die here what are those and I'm
not talking about my weird-ass little
shoes
let's go inside
that's cool man I will goodbye little
buddy
we're gonna keep going to the next level
to the next level
oh all right all right all right whoa is
this a snowman underwater dude it's like
fairy lights
fairy lights looks anything makes
anything look pretty look at this you
could literally slap fairy lights on
your mama's face and they she look good
I was gonna say my face but her lights
wouldn't say my face whoa
how you doing there buddy hey you got a
little oh that's cute that's adorable
you kind of freaked me out though I
guess I guess we're gonna ride are we
gonna ride are we gonna ride are we
gonna ride we're gonna ride we're gonna
write aren't we even all right whoa this
is coal
I want to do this never mind I don't
want to do this that's terrifying that's
way to any whales
oh god that's the mouth they're so big
please don't eat me whoa holy [ __ ]
whales are terrifying I don't know why
they're just way too big okay
it's scary oh hey hey hey y'all you
almost hit me there buddy
close call dude I'm trying to save the
ocean here
oh my mommy
Wow
oh where are we going where we going
we're at the bottom okay
all right sign makes me feel safe sign
makes me feel safe this is so cool okay
I'm well into this let me just make sure
that I'm actually recording sorry one
second I am okay great let's keep going
what is that sound
what are those I hate how I can't say
what are those anymore without
triggering that meme whoa what just
happen well I'm never gonna be curious
again thank you very much a goblin shark
goblin boy shark sounds horrific what
about this one
they're like mines or something
oh [ __ ] that's a big-ass skeleton
well front-flip ow ow it's a little crab
there this game is so detailed it's
amazing like a little diglettz to love
diglettz favorite Pokemon hands up oh no
it's these freaky ass fishes I hate them
like the deep-sea fishes oh wow okay
what is this is that a rock or what is
it is it a skeleton on a rock
whoa okay we got a shell this is so
crazy
a lot of dead whales down here buy a lot
of dead whales I bet cubone is gonna
come out that would make no sense
whatsoever
oh god you scare me okay there's
something here go away mines hey dig
let's how you doing buddy ah here we go
there we go
angler fish I know and that's the one I
was talking about the creepy looking
ones yeah [ __ ] those sorry why did I
leave hell up on this earth
whoo we got a cable we got a cable if
you get uh these are [ __ ] creepy dude
let's try and not get ourselves killed
Jesus dude
yeah that's right
ya dumb [ __ ] with me I'm the Cable Guy
okay one more cable then s Buzz cool now
we have a purpose now we know what to do
get the other cable and fast I'm gonna
go so fast Papa Papa Papa Papa Papa Papa
that's my sound effect to make myself go
faster trust me sonic uses it everyone
used to say world famous athletes use it
oh [ __ ] Oh God all right how could I not
see this
oh god I'm gonna die I'm literally gonna
die I'm gonna die I'm alive I'm alive ah
it's so loud alright it just sings a
little bit it's like a Pikachu thing I'm
playing way too much Pokemon go thank
you everyone
there we go we open the giant gate in
the bottom of the ocean what we're gonna
find I don't know oh it's that [ __ ] he
ate my share we saved man shut up about
the Pokemon [ __ ] hell
sorry front-flip hey super speed look at
that you got a front flip and then get
speed high do that whoa
flipping makes you speed man oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] go go go go go flip dude yeah
golden girl and fishies oh there is oh
well I guess you're [ __ ] now huh have
you thought about that mr. shark you
should have thought about you wanting my
help now well you should have thought
about that before you ate my friend look
at this front flip look at this front
flip bet you can't do [ __ ] or I fine
I'll save you Jesus Christ
alright just promise you won't eat me
oh boy yeah I [ __ ] up now oh no we're
swimming the Sharks everyone that's cool
okay well the guy in the game is clearly
insane I would never do this
look at that golden shoes man hey that's
a shell that's a shell if I didn't take
that shell everyone watching me play
this would freak the [ __ ] out oh no how
hey I got cat hears I just realized
that's really cute how am i I just
realized that no so many times like I
noticed that I'd missed something in the
playthrough while I ended it and I know
everyone's gonna want to kill me it's
like it physically hurts you guys if I
miss something sometimes I want to miss
stuff on purpose
oh god you guys are ugly wails I don't
like you guys whoa
okay we're going deeper everyone thank
you oh no those octopuses
oh I'm crunching for real oh I hate
those have you guys watched those like
deeper water
[ __ ] oh they find like these huge as
octopuses they're so scary I'm swimming
to it I'm legit cringing sorry sorry
just don't go near me Oh God the deep
ocean terrifies me man you don't even
know what's down there we don't even
know we don't even know what's down
there
think of all the ugly creatures
I mean it's beautiful everything in this
game is beautiful I I'm so sorry I just
Octopussy I can't is that what they're
called octopus ease all right it's time
to give this play some life
I think this could be our last or second
last I am not sure let's have a look one
two three
that's all last how is that possible
what
SuperSpeed hey look at that trick man
you just got to do a different one
I think to get it no there it is
totally hit that surely there's the last
one after this one don't worry okay I
got this pop-up it's got this oh no I'm
not down with this I'm not down with
those octopuses you know if I if I'm bad
in this life I'm gonna be reincarnated
that's one of those and it's not gonna
be good man it's not some Oh God it's a
lot of underwater stuff recently I just
watched a finding dory as well oh man
this makes me want to go to the Brighton
aquarium mart said would be thrilled she
literally wants me to go everyday okay
flip hey you SuperSpeed
out this shark to follow me excellent
thankfully we're going deeper we're
going deeper through the tiny little
hole going deeper the sexual innuendoes
right themselves I don't even have good
what is that how did that get there how
am I supposed to get through is I think
it's the real question we're just gonna
speed up give me speed give me speed ah
that it looks so [ __ ] cool I mean I'm
no I'm not here to [ __ ] comment about
the bad things Jesus that looks awesome
such different styles colliding I really
like it
alright dude you got to keep swimming
man do the flip there we go that went
pretty well next level we'll do one more
well do one more I'm really into this
and I want to keep playing
oh my god we're this is the end of Star
Fox 64 which was essentially ripped up
from Star Wars
you know what I'm talking about this is
so cool there you go take another shot
everyone
whoa
some kind of conveyor belt building
half-life 2 half-life 3 confirm
[ __ ] oh god
can't hit me
why do those things react to me that's
the real question there we go
find something what is that is that the
propeller thing it is it's got those
things in them
and that's in the [ __ ] so the last one
is in here maybe oh [ __ ] this is the
matrix now we turn into the matrix and
that's me and I have one in me oh god I
can't be good
guys back up are there with me okay cool
maybe this is my spaceship ooh that'd be
interesting
while regardless we're gonna keep going
there we go smooth like butters but not
a problem
Oh whoa that's a lot of things to go
through man oh boy oh boy uh gonna oh
[ __ ] they're down everywhere they're
everywhere they're everywhere they're
everywhere okay okay we're gonna take
this rap we're gonna take the road we're
gonna do the chicken rap [ __ ] I gotta go
up okay alright alright alright I know
dude I know that we got to go there but
dude they they're [ __ ] everywhere man
I can't even see where I'm going man ha
ha yeah now don't shock me no no no wow
that [ __ ] hurts man the curve Oh
scheisse make it stop make it stop
ah we got a window we got a window we're
gonna wind up way together window we
gotta [ __ ] they're blinking everywhere
they're blinking everywhere they're
blinking everyone guys I got I'm trying
to [ __ ] go forward third you're going
backwards
I'm sweating
they're swimming fast thing
Oh
Oh lap down right
press B aids-like start okay okay we did
it oh Jesus Christ
dude I do that so easily that was that
was pathetic how how easily I did that
well hello there little friend oh [ __ ]
is the mastermind is the self-aware
computer isn't it
Sharky Sharky saved me
oh no oh this is a bad one
that's why shark he killed the drone
shock is on my side oh I'm so sorry I'm
an idiot I'm an idiot shark is on my
side all alone okay Bruce I'm gonna have
to end it there this game is absolutely
incredible last part is going to be the
last one to make sure you don't miss it
it'll be up tomorrow I promise you thank
you so much for living in like that
really supports and help out and as
always stay awesome breaths so I guess
that's where the star fell or whatever
it is I don't know I do what are these
like great jumping sliding alright